How about we stop romanticizing everything
because we don't live in the motherfucking notebook, you know?
I know that every girl is just imagining that scene against the car,
like. And I'm gonna choose you,
and it's gonna be hard,
but I'm gonna choose you every day because I love you.
Like, oh,
my god, it's a fucking movie.
Just like we don't want men to look at corn
and assume that that's what that is supposed to be like in real life.
Women need to stop romanticizing everything
and thinking everything is gonna be magical and beautiful.
Come the fuck on. Come the fuck on.
Be so fucking for real. Do we tell our sons that?
You know what, buddy?
When you grow up, you don't have to worry about figuring shit out
or knowing how to financially pay for yourself in any capacity.
Just find a friend that you can live with and support
and just making arrangement with them,
because that's. That's a totally fine option in life.
No, we don't do that.
We don't set our sons up for that type of dependency on someone else.
We teach them to be independent and grown and.
But we're gonna tell our daughters,
just go be a baby making machine.
Just go ahead and use that vagina so that when you're done,
people will call you, run through,
and you have no other option.
No, that's. No.
And if we go back to the video,
I'm not attacking Her. I start the video out by saying, tribewives,
you need to understand that your husbands are kind of fucking weird.
The reason why that article with Ballerina Farm went south
was cause her fucking husband got involved.
And because you could see the realities of her life.
How drowning in children she is,
how much the children, small children,
are tasked with caring for each other.
And the journalist was simply stating these things,
facts that they saw, facts that are realities in any home
where there are nine children and not much fucking help
and moms busy cooking every goddamn aspect of everything by scratch.
So I'm not attacking her.
Women need to fucking get off your high fucking horse.
Realize that like someone,
there's no. There's no jealousy,
no animosity.
Sometimes another woman is truly just trying to look out for you
and be like, hey,
maybe there are some drawbacks to that lifestyle.
Maybe other people can see that your husband's kind of weird
and controlling.
I wasn't attacking her. I'm not even attacking her husband.
I'm just saying like, hey, guys,
just so you know, I'm not saying this with any.
Anything in my heart other than love and concern,
because I was a tribe wife for 10 years.
I did all that shit. I maybe wasn't on a 300 acre farm,
but I like, gardened in the little spots that I could
and did everything that I could of the lifestyle.
And I gotta Tell ya, it's not all that it's made out to be.
And the aftermath for your life is pretty fucking ugly.
So watch the fuck out.